Greetings and welcome to earthling
cinema.
I am your host Garrick's where ameloid.
This week's artifact is spiderman
homecoming starring Tom Hollandaise
sauce and praised by fans as the
installment that bravely made aunt may
hot.
The film follows teenage earthling,
Peter Parker,
who is Hashtag blessed with sticky hand
powers.
One day Peter Fights for playboy
billionaire Elon Musk in the civil war,
but before Ilan can ulysses s grant him
a spot on the avengers.
Peter has to prove himself by just sort
of stopping crime with no clear
deadlines or goals.
Fortunately,
a garbage man named tombs has been busy
selling artists and weapons on etsy and
dressing like a bird.
Spiders sworn enemies behind water
spouts at school.
Peter spends his time macking on his
crush.
Liz chillin with is obligatory ugly fat
friend,
Ned and macking on his crush.
Liz while chatting with is obligatory
fat friend Ned afterschool.
He looks for crime only.
Define New York City is too safe.
That is until tombs is men forget their
pin number and have to use a ray gun.
They escape,
but Peter does manage to blow up a deli.
Peter slings back home where ned learns
Peter's deepest secret.
He still plays with Legos.
Oh,
Andy Spiderman.
That too.
When ned coyly implies Peter knows
spiderman.
He didn't know sweater man.
They score tickets to Liz's weeknight
ranger,
but the party has cut short.
When tombs is men sell guns to childish
Gumby.
Peter Mixes it up by using all the same
tactics and gets dropped on his head
like my son relax.
He was a baby armed with a ninth grade
education.
Ned and Peter decrypted Doodad and Geo
locate tunes to Washington DC,
the criminal capital of the universe.
Peter gets a rematch with Birdman,
but ends up in an Amazon prime warehouse
where he hits it off with his ostp.
Samantha.
So where would you like to take me
tonight?
It's really nice to have somebody to
talk to.
Speaking of hitting it off,
ned turns the Doodad into a bomb causing
an explosion in the monument to
Washington's penis.
Peter Saves his classmates heroically
costing the taxpayers millions.
Back in the big apple store,
Peter Interrogates Childish Gumby
without a warrant.
Since this is America,
he tells him to check the ocean bus
where tunes goes.
Rip Ship.
Ilan glues the ship back together,
but takes back his suit.
Leaving Peter to walk home naked.
Peter Asks Liz to homecoming,
get it.
Of course you don't,
but when he gets to her house,
a shocking Pepsi twist is revealed.
Birdman is Liz's dad who's anti spider
kill you and everybody love and pro gun.
Since it's act three,
Peter Decides to stop bird man's latest
scheme,
robbing an airplane full of avengers.
Merge tombs tries the old,
I'm going to drop a building on your
face trick,
but Peter Remembers he has super
strength and thoughts is planned by
crashing the plane into an area full of
tourists having utterly reckless his
life.
Peter says goodbye.
Ilan offers peter a job at tesla,
but peter declines.
Oh yeah.
Aunt may was in this spiderman
homecoming marries the superhero action
shondra and the teen comedy genre with a
license at got online.
The film is stylized like John Hughes
Jones,
both through homages to Ferris Bueller
doesn't go to college pretty in Pinko
and the one about breakfast and through
its themes of teenagers exploring
identity,
romance,
and hats,
it gives me confidence through the lens
of a kid growing up.
The film updates the Sony Spiderman
ethos with great power comes great
responsibility and 10 more reboots.
Usually this is interpreted as meaning
that since Peter has great power,
he has the obligation to use it for the
utmost good of society.
But homecoming inverts this by
questioning whether the young Peter is
responsible enough to wield great power.
I know anything.
What do you want me to do?
I think you've done in the beginning,
Peter is impulsive and fails to think
through the consequences of his use of
power,
not so different from the criminals who
sell nuclear weapons to people without
conducting a background check.
He considers using his power for
frivolous means such as crashing Liz's
party as Spiderman for the gram and jail
breaking his suit before reading up on
Windows Vista.
His father figure Ilan has to repeatedly
swoop in and clean up his mess,
usually in a tesla,
ultimately taking away a suit so he can
dry clean it.
It's only when Peter realizes that his
actions make things explode all the time
that he grows up.
Ironically realizing he is not ready to
wield such power until the sql spiderman
home depot.
In a note of intertextual irony,
Michael Keaton appears as an avian
villain on the heels of 2014 Oscar
Darling Birdman or the unexpected value
of shooting off your nose in it.
Keaton's character falls into obscurity
after starring in a superhero franchise,
much as Keaton did after his starring
role in Batman,
although who could forget Jack Frost,
literally every human after they
lobotomized it from their brains.
This role becomes an ironic completion
of Birdman and that the film made Keaton
relevant enough to return to lucrative
franchises and play the underdog to mega
stars like Robert Downey Jr and 16 time
Oscar winner Zendaya for earthlink
cinema.
I'm Garrick's wormy Lloyd and a case you
hadn't heard.
I've started my own channel to see all
future episodes and subscribe.
Be sure to click here.
[inaudible].